okay I told you when Donald Trump
declared this bogus national emergency
over the non-existent crisis at the
us-mexico border that there would be
legal challenges and indeed there are
sixteen states have now filed the
lawsuit over Donald Trump's declaration
of a national emergency to try to
commandeer money from the military and
the Department of Defense to build a
border wall sixteen states Colorado
Connecticut Delaware Hawaii Illinois
Maryland Maine Michigan Minnesota
yes Minnesota almost at Minneapolis
Nevada New Jersey New Mexico New York
Oregon and Virginia all participating in
this lawsuit which claims primarily that
this declaration of a national emergency
is a misuse of presidential power and
there's a couple of different ways that
this can be argued and we'll see as this
progresses which is the path that
actually is employed here number one is
the argument that historically and I
told you this yesterday in part
historically national emergencies have
been used to expedite either funding or
action on issues that have bipartisan
support
so sanctions on particular people around
the world delivering aid somewhere
declaring a particular situation a
disaster zone or a humanitarian crisis
or whatever the idea is there is
bipartisan support and the declaration
of the national emergency helps to
further the position of the House and
Senate in order to more quickly achieve
something Donald Trump's doing the
opposite here there's no congressional
consensus for funding his border wall
Donald Trump has chosen to use the
declaration of a national emergency not
to more quickly do what Congress is
trying to do but to actually do the
opposite of what Congress has shown a
willingness to do to circumvent the
hesitation of Congress the house in the
Senate to fund Donald Trump's bogus
border walls so as I said if you're a
small government conservative you should
be furious at what Donald Trump is doing
if you believe in checks and balances
you should be furious of
this decision if you are against
expanding executive branch power and the
power of the office of the presidency
which many small government
conservatives claim to be against then
you have to be against this if you don't
even care about any of that stuff and
you just believe in facts and logic you
have to realize that there is no factual
case to be made that there is a crisis
on the southern border the facts just
don't bear it out and I won't even
repeat the full list again because it's
it's total broken record circumstances
at this point on that issue now there
may also be lawsuits coming from red
states the actual border states were the
for the wall would go because there are
right-wingers who made generally
speaking believe that there's an
immigration crisis or like the idea of a
border wall but there are right-wingers
who own land on the border who don't
want the government taking their land
for the wall particularly on the basis
of a national emergency declared by the
president going around the will of
Congress what is really important here
is that the lawsuits aren't about the
wall per se they are lawsuits about
executive branch overreach on the basis
of a declaration by the president
seizing money and seizing potentially
property land and the argument pad is
that this makes it a constitutional
issue and the best-case scenario is that
this takes years to resolve nothing gets
built and eventually a Democratic
president says there's no more emergency
and we're not trying to build the wall I
see that as the sort of best path
forward to tie this thing up
indefinitely that does sound like the
right path forward and everyone knew
that these lawsuits were going to happen
including the President himself he
mentioned that during his national
emergency speech and honestly if the
courts do strike this down in time I
don't think he'll care that much I think
he just wanted to deliver this campaign
promise to his supporters and he's going
to come to the polls in 2020 and say
that I did what I could I tried to build
the wall through Congress I tried to do
it through a national emergency
and the court struck me down and
everyone's against me but his supporters
will still view this as a as an attempt
at winning like he'd like he'd tried to
fulfill his campaign promise isn't it
sort of weird that they claim to be
against socialism but a lot of them are
okay with the government seizing both
taxpayer land and taxpayer money by
circumventing Congress to build a wall
aren't those the bad elements of
socialism that they claim to be again
it's a very very strange thing we'll see
what happens now this could be you know
we've been reporting on it daily since
the Declaration of the national
emergency but we may get to a point
where there's very little to say about
it because it's just going to be tied up
in courts for years which i think would
actually be a pretty good outcome